thanks to curiositystream for keeping
legal eagle in the air
i don't know about you but it seems like
every celebrity wants their own
trademark these days the summer of 2019
was filled with such
celebrity trademark news as tom brady
wanting to trademark
tom terrific for some reason lebron
james filed an application to register
the trademark for
taco tuesday and lizzo says she's the
only one who can call herself
100 that [ __ ] sure it's all fun and
games until lebron james takes away your
right to send pictures of your food with
the hashtag
taco tuesday to your friends here comes
lebron
so what is going on with celebrities and
the u.s patent and trademark office
anyway
[Music]
hey legal eagles today we are talking
about celebrity trademarks but first
what is a trademark well a trademark is
a word symbol or phrase
that's used to identify a particular
manufacturer or a particular product to
distinguish them from the
products of another company or person
for example coke and pepsi have
different logos that's how you can be
assured that you are grabbing a
delicious diet coke
rather than a clearly inferior diet
pepsi though obviously we can all agree
that dr pepper is by far the best
carbonated soda out there now the
federal law that protects trademarks
used in commerce is called the lanham
act
the u.s patent and trademark office or
uspto for short
is in charge of granting federal
trademark protection trademarks are
often confused with copyright but
they're two very different concepts and
they cover different rights
copyright protects original works of
creative authorship fixed in a tangible
medium
that means that authors and artists have
the exclusive right to do whatever they
want with the things that they make for
a limited amount of time
whether that's a book a song a movie a
photograph a sculpture or anything else
that qualifies for
copyright protection for example if you
write a novel you don't need to register
your book or ask the government to
provide a certificate proving that you
wrote it
once your book is fixed in a tangible
medium in other words it's written down
in some
form it's protected by copyright law and
no one else can copy your book or adapt
it for the big screen
for instance without your permission
trademarks on the other hand are very
different they don't cover creative
expression per se
a trademark is not about rewarding the
trademark holder the goal of trademark
protection
is not just to protect the person or
business from having their trademark
stolen
it's all about preventing consumer
confusion if you own the rights to a
certain trademark
you can sue someone else from using a
trademark that seems similar to yours to
prevent consumers from being confused to
prove that someone infringed on your
trademark you need to show that it's
likely to cause consumer confusion about
the source
of the product or service at issue let
me give you an example
adidas has trademarked its distinctive
three stripe logo
which it places on everything from shoes
to hats to track pants
forever 21 sells trendy clothes
including sometimes clothes
that seem to have the same three stripe
pattern that you would usually find
on adidas clothes adidas sued for
copyright infringement in 2017.
the problem was that the striped sweats
that forever 21 was selling
looked exactly like authentic adidas
clothes it looked like something adidas
would actually produce
the parties eventually settled out of
court but it's very likely that adidas
would have won that suit with a
trademark the point is to make sure that
consumers
know who made the product or service
when you see the familiar adidas stripe
pattern on clothes
you know what kinds of products they
sell and the values associated with that
particular brand
you can also trademark phrases and
packaging things like short phrases and
even
single words that would never be
protected by copyright because they're
too short and not creative enough
that actually might qualify for
trademark protection again for the
purpose of preventing consumer confusion
for a mark to qualify for registration
with a trademark office it needs to be
distinctive this is based on how well
the trademark identifies the source or
manufacture of a certain product or
service
there are four types of distinctive
marks fanciful marks are inherently
distinctive because
they have no meaning outside of that
which is gained in the context of
selling a good or service
the word google for example doesn't mean
anything it's just a made-up name that
is now associated with an internet
service provider
the same is true of kodak xerox or exxon
these are the strongest kinds of
trademarks because
they don't have any meaning outside of
the trademark itself the next strongest
form of mark is an arbitrary mark which
is something that already has a common
meaning
but doesn't have a connection to the
goods or services being sold
apple is a fruit but it's also a
computer lotus
is a software but it's also a plant
these are highly protectable because
they are
arbitrary compared to the thing being
sold next there are suggestive marks
which refer to some quality or
characteristic of the good
a jaguar for example is a name of a
super sleek cat but that's also why the
car company chose that name to associate
the characteristics of the cat with its
cars and then finally we have
descriptive trademarks which simply
describe the service or goods
a descriptive trademark is weak since it
doesn't do anything to identify the
source of the product or service or it's
pretty hard to create that
identification
if something is merely descriptive it
will not qualify
for registration so for example if i
start a bowl company named cereal bowl
it's unlikely the uspto would grant me a
trademark
i could still use cereal bowl for my
company name but
i have a hard time stopping others from
using it because it's merely a
descriptive
mark but if i called a new clothing
company's cereal bowl
that would be an arbitrary mark and
could be very strong because
why would you associate the words cereal
bowl with a clothing company it's
arbitrary and it's very likely to be
able to identify
cereal bowl clothes oh god i'm so hungry
for some cereal and some dr pepper right
now
in addition to the distinctiveness
requirement for any particular mark
you also have to use the mark in
commerce before you can get protection
from the uspto trademark has sort of a
use it or
lose it provision now in some cases you
can declare your intent to use a mark
and get protection but that's temporary
and still requires use in commerce in
the short term
now say you have two similar marks the
question is whether there would be a
likelihood of consumer confusion between
the two marks
on top of that even if the two marks are
very very similar
in fact sometimes they can be identical
using exactly the same words
a likelihood of confusion will only be
found to exist
where the goods or the underlying
services are in fact connected or
related
what most people get wrong about
trademark is that a trademark only
covers a narrow
set of goods or services just because
you have a trademark over a specific
word
doesn't mean that you can monopolize
that word throughout the entire universe
you only get potential control over
similar goods or services that use a
confusingly similar mark
in commerce that's why wolf ranges can
exist
at the same time as wolf clothing or why
apple records which was started by the
beatles could exist at the same time
as apple computers which was started by
steve jobs though that's probably not a
great example because apple records an
apple computer suit each other
for decades although maybe it is a good
example because
in the 1970s computers didn't really
have anything to do with music
so there was no real overlap between
apple records and
apple computers but as computers became
able to make
and play music overlap was created
especially when apple computers started
making
ipods and the itunes music store at that
point it was
very possible that consumers might be
confused between the two marks
for example if you heard the phrase
apple music in 2005
odds are you probably thought of steve
jobs rather than paul mccartney and
that's why
apple records and apple computers were
in lawsuits with each other for the
better part of 40 years here's another
example since i have tennis on the brain
since the us open is currently on
roger federer is one of the most popular
and famous tennis players of all time
his name and likeness are powerful for
selling goods and it gives him the
ability to get paid big bucks to endorse
products like rolex lint chocolates
uniqlo and nike
if roger federer could not protect his
name and likeness
then maybe i could show up at the u.s
open selling special socks
supposedly endorsed by roger federer and
i'm sure
i'd be able to sell a lot of them
trademarks are about preventing market
confusion
my federer socks could hoodwink a lot of
people and it's exactly that reason why
the uspto denied trademark registration
for rob kardashian's
ex blac chyna when she tried to take the
kardashian name
blac chyna tried to register the name
angela kardashian
when she was engaged to rob kardashian
his sisters successfully blocked her
attempt to register that trademark
the various kardashian companies and
kardashian people
have powerful brands that have generated
hundreds of millions of dollars the
uspto agreed with kardashians that if
blac chyna started endorsing products
with the name angela kardashian
the product would inevitably be
considered part of the kardashian brand
in particular that's called trademark
dilution because you are diluting the
power
of that particular mark and in that
particular instance that's probably
considered trademark
passing off where you're trying to pass
off your goods as being affiliated with
somebody else
and both of those are no-no's as far as
trademark law goes
but it was easy to see why blac chyna
was eager to capitalize on that name and
it was also easy to see why the
kardashians wanted to stop her
so let's talk about some of these
celebrity trademark names that are in
the news today
as the would-be angela kardashian
recognized registering a name has become
increasingly popular
however to really enjoy the protections
of trademark law you have to promise to
use that name
in commerce if you don't use the name
your trademark will disappear you'll
abandon that trademark
many celebrities have been criticized
for trying to trademark their kids names
they usually say that they have no
intention of ever making money on the
name of their child
they just want to be able to stop other
people from capitalizing on their
children's name
but this legal tactic doesn't really
work since trademarks are given
specifically for use in commerce
you have to use them to get a trademark
and even then they would only apply to
similar goods are children goods no
no they are not so it didn't go well for
beyonce and jay-z when they tried to
register the mark for
their daughter blue ivy a boston company
called blue iv elements beat them to the
punch demonstrating that they had used
the mark blue ivy
since at least 2009 and four years later
the carters tried again this time trying
to register blue ivy carter
but they insisted the reason that they
needed the trademark was to stop
others from using it once again blue ivy
events contested the filing and they
accused the carters of trademark fraud
since they claimed to have no intention
of actually using the name
for goods or services and once again the
carters were defeated because you
can't just try to monopolize a
particular name
which brings us to whether tom brady can
trademark the term
tom terrific nicknames actually can be
eligible for trademark that was clearly
what tom brady thought when he tried to
file the trademark registration for the
nickname tom terrific
when brady's registration attempt became
public he backpedaled claiming that he
just wanted to stop people from
associating the name with him because he
thought it was stupid
i was actually trying to do something
because i didn't like the nickname
and i want to make sure no one used it
because some people wanted to use it
what that makes absolutely no legal
sense when you file a trademark you have
to show that it is closely associated
with the thing you intend to use it for
in the marketplace
not that you are hoping that people will
never call you tom terrific and that you
want the trademark specifically to stop
people from using it and that you
yourself
will never use it because you hate that
particular nickname i would love to hear
the communications between brady and his
lawyer did he just call him up and say
hey some guy on espn saw my comeback
last week and is now calling me tom
terrific
send that guy a cease and desist letter
not surprisingly we already know what
the uspto thinks of this particular
brady trademark registration because it
has already denied the application
the uspto not only noticed that brady
had no intent to really use it in
commerce
but also the nickname includes a matter
which may falsely suggest a connection
to
tom seaver tom seaver for those of you
who are younger than the age of 70
is a former major league baseball
pitcher who started for the 1969
mets he was so good that the media gave
him the nicknames tom terrific
and the franchise because of that the
uspto
held that quote the mark tom terrific
points uniquely and
unmistakably to tom seaver and the fame
or reputation of tom seaver as tom
terrific
is such that a connection between mr
siever and the applied for goods
would be presumed again the uspto is
telling us that consumer confusion
is key products featuring the nickname
could make you think
seaver endorsed or approved them and the
uspto also thought
it was significant that seaver is alive
and didn't consent to the brady
trademark registration
this is the kind of misuse of the legal
system that really grinds my gears
brady's attempt to grab the trademark
was an attempt to control speech he just
wanted people to not
call him tom terrific but frankly i
don't think we can let this stand
even though brady is on my fantasy
football team let's start a movement to
start calling him
tom terrific brady hashtag tom terrific
brady which brings us to
famous catch phrases like taco tuesdays
it is possible to trademark certain
catchphrases but only for the protection
of its use in connection with goods or
services
just saying a catchphrase doesn't make
it something that you can register
but you can use the catchphrase in
connection with goods and services
you can also stop someone else from
profiting from your catchphrase in a
similar industry
when it comes to registering
catchphrases taylor swift is a frequent
filer
she has filed trademark applications for
the names of her albums like reputation
lyrics from her songs like the old
taylor can't come to the phone right now
and even
the name of her world tours like the
1989 world tour
but swift doesn't always win
registration for her trademarks that's
because in order to get them you need to
prove that it's more than just a thing
that
she said one time which brings us to
lebron can lebron james register taco
tuesday
one of lebron's companies filed a
trademark application on august 15
stating that he intended to use the term
taco tuesday in his business ventures
lebron has had a fun summer
instagramming his family's enjoyment of
weekly taco meals
it's tuesday somewhere so you know what
that means
[Music]
so much fun that his company says he
intends to start an empire of products
and podcasts using the phrase but
lebron's quest may be as doomed to
failure as his first season as a laker
that's right i said it a wyoming
restaurant called taco john's got the
taco tuesday trademark way back in 1982.
taco john's is a small western franchise
but it has defended its trademark with
some success
however the trademark is considered
relatively weak since it's merely
descriptive it
isn't fanciful or original it's a phrase
that many people have used for decades
to describe the fact that they're eating
tacos
on tuesdays and it's not necessarily
something that you hear and immediately
think i should go to taco john's right
now
that's probably why restaurants
everywhere have used taco tuesdays in
promotions
so lebron is starting with two strikes
one is that another company already uses
the trademark taco tuesday
and two the trademark is descriptive of
something that people do
they eat a bunch of tacos on tuesday it
isn't
truly associated with lebron or his
products in any particular way
as a result the uspto is likely to deny
lebron's trademark the same way that
they denied brady
so finally that takes us to lizzo lizzo
is taking the world by storm in 2019 so
the senior decided to take things to the
next level
by applying for a trademark for the
phrase 100 that [ __ ] from her song
truth hurts
i just took a dna test turns out i'm 100
lizzo says that she intends to use the
phrase on clothing and entertainment
services
some people have called out lizzo
because she didn't invent the phrase
as far as anyone knows the first person
to gain traction with that phrase on the
internet was singer mina leonis who
tweeted back in 2017
quote i did a dna test and i found out
i'm 100
that [ __ ] which i probably don't need
to tell you is hilarious
mina's tweet became a viral moment and
an incredibly popular mean
so yes it's true that lizzo didn't
invent the phrase but does that prevent
her from
filing a trademark not really this isn't
a copyright claim where
originality and creativity are
incredibly important
and where you can use that kind of
protection to stop another person from
stealing their work
that phrase is probably so short that it
wouldn't receive copyright protection
so the verdict well in trademark law
we're most interested in whether a
person has claimed a mark
as their own by using it in commerce i
mean it had a viral moment but didn't do
anything
with it as far as goods or services go
she didn't start a company with that
name she didn't slap it on some t-shirts
or even use it in the title of her next
album so that probably means
it's fair game for lizzo provided that
she actually uses it
for a bona fide reason in goods or
services that she provides
now tom terrific brady is great isn't he
or if you don't live in boston maybe you
just think he's 100
that [ __ ] either way he's not the
perfect athlete if creating the perfect
athlete is something that you're
interested in there is a fascinating
documentary on curiosity stream called
the quest for the perfect athlete it's
about how
psycho-cognitive training is carried out
in certain professional teams
to push athletes even further to win
world records
and super bowls and world series so
someday
tom will be even more terrific it is a
great watch and one of thousands of
documentaries you can watch on curiosity
stream
it's the first streaming service that
exclusively streams documentaries and
educational videos
and was created by the founders of the
discovery channel
with them you can watch these docs on
almost every platform including android
and apple tv
unlimited access on curiosity stream is
only 299 per month but the best part is
that you can start watching curiosity
stream for free for 30 days
by signing up at curiositystream.com
legaleagle
and using the code legaleagle at
checkout using the promo code really
helps out the channel again that's
curiositystream.com legaleagle so click
on the link in the dooblydoo and get
curiosity stream for free for 30 days
but what do you guys think do you think
that celebrities are
out of line by trying to trademark these
phrases and names or do you think it is
a perfectly reasonable way to protect
against consumer confusion
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
where i have all of my other
real law reviews where we talk about all
of the pressing legal issues of the day
so click on the playlist and i'll see
you in court